i have a question what is like one food
trend
that you thought this will never stick
around
this is you know what it's gone but it's
still here
yeah good question um i started
uh looking at brain foods about five
years ago in terms of
you know there was a study shown in
alzheimer's disease in terms of what was
necessary to stimulate the brain and it
was uh in connection with larry rouvo
at that incredible medical center in
vegas so uh
turmeric was an amazing way of
waking up the brain and stimulating the
cells to sort of become more creative so
um spice is something that i've been
working with on a lot
not just the dry spice but you know even
a basic five spice you know added that
to
uh a seasoning over a chicken drum or
chicken breast
it goes a long way so spice has been
literally everywhere over the last two
or three years
i thought that the brain epicenter is in
vegas
i just think that's awesome it's like
get a clear head
and then go nuts or go nuts
and then get a clear head and lather
rinse repeat
every time i go to vegas i go all out i
it's not like the hangover level but
it's it's in the vein of
um i think i've just been cut off
um okay uh we have a friend of the show
who is also totally amazing and awesome
on tick-tock and he's just i love him so
much
he's so special he spans the ages
i love an all-ages party and everyone's
invited eton bernath is joining us
now he's a huge fan of yours hi aton
hi drew good morning i'm super excited
to be here
this is our like third or fourth time
doing the show together
and um eton i know that you have some
questions for gordon
and a fun twist um with every
uh answer that you get right we're gonna
donate basically if you get it in 60
seconds we're donating 5 000
to your make-a-wish charity so aton
without further ado let's get into it
okay are you ready set right on
all right gordon what is one dish that
you are still yet to tackle or you're
still a little free
i would say it would be a chocolate
souffle
interesting now what is your most
essential tool in the kitchen when
you're cooking
would be the sharpest knife on the
planet oh i have to agree with that one
i feel like the knife is everything
now me and drew love weird food
combination so what is the weirdest food
combination that you love that like
everyone thinks you're crazy for
um i would say um scrambled eggs and
white truffle has to be
an absolute dream come true it doesn't
sound weird to me that sounds delicious
and is there any foods that you won't
try i know you're all about trying like
crazy foods is there something that you
just won't
try i'm not good eight on with phones
i think foam should be kept for shaving
um not eating so not big on phones they
look disgusting
who is the most influential mentor in
your life
that would have to be uh giselle the
most amazing chef from paris that we
worked together
in vegas amazing guy awesome there we go
it was so fun interview although it's
still on my bucket list
to be cooking and getting yelled at you
so let's make that happen one time
i can't wait for that eight time eitan
you are
just the greatest in the world i love
you so much and i'm so glad that we got
to hang out with gordon ramsay together
and quite the morning i know i know i
saw on your instagram you were like
outside the door and i was like i'll see
you in a few hours
um okay so we're gonna donate five
thousand dollars to your cooking up
wishes fundraiser with make a wish
and you know i oh also
cookbook club yes do you have a cookbook
i have a cookbook for you
wow that it'll be useful it's ama
by jose or sorry uh jose centeno
he's the most amazing mexican food chef
he's california-based and i am obsessed
with him i've been to all his
restaurants he's really special
so this is my cookbook club offering to
you
i get one two i'm so excited this is for
you on its way to
new york now it's called restore and
it's from an amazing uh
girl called gizzy erickson and she's all
about eating properly
but sustainable and so it's a really
good way of utilizing readings that you
never thought could be elevated
and this thing only arrived yesterday
and it's going straight back off to the
post
literally minutes from now on its way to
new york for you restore
oh gordon thank you so much all my
cookbooks face
out in the kitchen i'm i have floor to
ceiling little narrow shelves so that i
can
i am obsessed and i'm obsessed with you
and i really appreciated and loved what
you said earlier
and i think everything you do and put
out into the world
and you've done so many things i mean
think about all the television shows
all the restaurants all the michelin
stars all the cookbooks
i've been thinking a lot about
especially in this pandemic and in this
year
we're always thinking about all the
things that we need to do
and i want to encourage us to think
about the things that we have
done and if you put that into
application when it comes to you
it's it's very incredible
and we all love you and we're rooting
for you
and we can't wait to watch you do
everything you do
tell people the truths and get them
moving forward in life thank you gordon
and tune in tuesday december 8th at 12
30 11 30 central on gordon's youtube
page
for this special charity event cooking
up wishes and all the proceeds
we'll be going to make a wish and if you
go to our website for more information
you'll see everything and season 19.
19 of hell's kitchen is premiering on
january
7th at 8 7 central on fox
you're dope good rad drew take care my
darling happy holidays and thank you
thank you thank you so much and thank
[Music]
you